all right well well my friends my
friends listen heed my words we're gonna
build back better baby because we got
breaking news this is amazing 4.3
million americans quit their jobs in
august a new record
great resignation trend continues as job
market upended by pandemic wow this is
amazing news let's get a round of let's
go brandon everybody let's go bro
yeah this is great thank you thank you
uh joe biden let's go brandon for the
mass resignations during a supply
shortage cargo ships being jammed up
trucker shortages labor food gas prices
skyrocketing now 4.3 million people in
august quit their jobs i wonder what the
numbers for september are that's when
the mandate was issued and it's also
important to understand that ag again a
lot of people here are are putting
themselves in a situation knowing that
they're going to lose everything and
they're saying i might as well just get
out of this crazy situation if they're
going to be enforcing this and move on
and find another way find another job so
i wouldn't be surprised if most of those
resignations most of those people
quitting were from big companies who
were mandating this and them saying no
i'm not going to go along with this and
i need an out now check this out they
say approximately four million people
per month have been leaving their job
since the spring as part of a trend that
has become known as the great
resignation
under joe biden's presidency for some
reason everybody is
everybody's quitting their jobs
right that's that's amazing that's good
it's a good thing it's almost like
there's a yeah it's it's a good thing um
yeah the economy is being reset at a
great level that's what it sounds like
to me i was just gonna say having this
many people resign in the course of a
month that sounds like a really big
reset resignation for the reset nation
exactly yes it does it's terrifying i
wonder what's going to happen because
people who are
familiar with how supply chains work
know how bottlenecks work right if you
get if you get something that's
constricting and slowing down so right
now there's a lot of backlogged ports
suppose
five percent of truckers
resign because they don't want to get
vaccinated and suppose five percent of
ship
uh captains resign and suppose five
percent of say
warehouse
workers resign that's a lot more
friction on an already stressed system
that bottleneck is going to back up in a
real hurry and the question is going to
be what's it going to take to be able to
get out these vaccine mandates if if
they are the cause of this of these
resignations this is going to hit supply
chain stuff and that supply chain stuff
is going to get way worse before it gets
better and the question becomes at a
certain point how do you even unload
those ports
what are you going to do
well walmart home depot these stores are
all chartering private boats now
this is it's really really amazing i
mean look we had 20 20 was bad right and
we can say donald trump did a good job
in 2010 is a great economy 2020 covet
hits and then things aren't so good but
we're supposed to be recovering joe
budden has turned what is supposed to be
a rapid resurgence as we reopen into a
complete complete catastrophe yeah and
and to be fair we love to just throw it
at joe biden because he's the president
but it's his administration every single
one of them involved if he promises
something he should be held accountable
for it he also promised the coveted
numbers to go down they've been going up
dramatically with more intervention more
governments getting involved and again
even when it comes to the ports there's
so many things to unwind there because
in the mainstream media like we saw in
this article by the independent this is
all pandemic related you know job loss
economic suffering inequalities this is
all pandemic this is all because of the
sickness no it's not it's because of the
government it's because of big fat cat
bureaucrats intervening making the
situation that much worse and not really
helping anyone out especially when you
look at the scientific data and you see
direct intervention mandates
restrictions lockdowns and you see
places that didn't follow it you look at
the cases you look at the numbers the
hospitalizations the debts there's not a
big difference there at all and some
would argue that the situation has been
exacerbated to its fullest extent with
the ports there's there's literal ships
that are ready to dock they can't
because one of their workers tested sick
what what do many of these boats have to
do they can't just wait it out they have
to go back to their country of origin
where they started from so we're talking
about ships that were in the philippines
that are in california have to go back
to the to the philippines there's labor
unions a part of these
trade routes that are saying please stop
with these ridiculous lockdowns with
these ridiculous restrictions they make
absolutely no sense at all the laws that
you guys have implemented here are
absolutely backwards meanwhile you have
the southern border wide open but if you
come into the united states you need a
negative test the work
quarantine actually comes from it's
italian from the 1660s uh ship suspected
of carrying contagious disease would
have to wait in port for 40 days the
quarantine
interesting
yeah you guys ever see that episode of
seinfeld where george castanza decides
to do the opposite of what he normally
does
it's almost like that's that's joe biden
but we're trying like he's like
you know do do the opposite of what what
so everything goes wrong the the ports
are all backed up but the borders wide
open drug cartels are smuggling drugs in
but we can't get our christmas toys
that's right
why
the one thing that should be here can't
and the one thing that's not supposed to
be here is yeah talk about a guy doing
the opposite of what's what's supposed
to be happening hunter biden is happy
though he's getting uh whatever he wants
so
again we talked about his uh approval
numbers and we said it's probably the
taliban it's probably the cartel members
that are the ones that are saying we're
very happy with what's happening right
now because everyone else is just
looking around and i think a lot of
people are ashamed that they even voted
for biden i'm not seeing anyone support
joe biden i'm not seeing anyone make any
defenses except for uh sellouts who get
hired to do it whether it's influencers
actors they're the only ones publicly
supporting they're having a hard time
even pulling that off it's punk rock
again yeah now that joe biden's approval
rating is in the gutter it is once again
punk rock to oppose
joe to to don't support support to
support joe biden yes because now most
people don't like him
so uh now that most people don't like
him i am uh i actually like him oh okay
because i'm i'm i'm punk rock what do
you like most about him his eyes
his hair i mean his beady eyes that
barely barely are up dude
i like his grubby little hands
cheering for biden is so mainstream man
it was it was for a long time i wonder
now what will happen now that people are
starting to hate him will celebrities
now be like
joe biden sucks no the question for me
is
just just looking at how how the
politics of this are shaping up biden
was brought in on a wave of anybody but
trump
i wonder what is going to happen if
trump throws his hat back in the ring i
don't know what trump is going to do but
suppose trump throws his hat back into
the ring
now your people are going to get to say
okay we're gonna trump can run on his
record and joe biden is going to run on
his record and i wonder what that looks
like
how
what what media environment does that
create what new levels of inauthenticity
will the media reach what new levels of
fakery will show up when you all of the
sudden
because when biden was running it was
always he was
basically running on obama's record i
was obama's vice president
therefore everyone goes okay well how
were the years during obama well that i
guess maybe wasn't the worst thing in
the world and they hate trump so fine
they can pull the lever for biden now
biden has a track record
now people get to look at biden and say
this is what we're going to vote for
four more years of
now they'll take trump yeah we're seeing
trump support go up in a lot of key
areas i want to correct you a little bit
because biden wasn't running the media
was running for biden and biden was
literally in a basement and they were
keeping him there making sure he wasn't
out there to the general public so so
now the media is even questioning biden
and and being like wait wait wait hold
on
what do we have on our hands here we
have a president that doesn't even want
to talk to us that literally says he's
gonna get in trouble if he gives us a
comment yeah we're having record low
ratings we're we're showing for a guy
that that literally doesn't even know
what's going on doesn't even know where
he is that literally created one of the
worst disasters in geopolitical history
with afghanistan
and they're looking around at the utter
chaos and devastation and i think even a
lot of people in the media are going to
have a very hard time shilling for him
again in 2024 and i don't think he's
going to be running i think it's i think
he's not going to be the candidate it's
impossible with the the havoc that he is
wrecking on the american people it'd be
too good it would it would be too too
good for uh the republicans and for the
for the anti-establishment so they need
to pull him out and then get some kind
of do-over with but i i i i don't know
honestly i don't even know who to name
who who is harrison no no no
no no one likes her she's worse than
she's like yeah she's like hillary but
worse
some people like biden
who likes biden but i guess i'm not like
like thirteen percent of the population
now hold on there a minute let me ask
you a question
if someone came to you and told you that
they liked say uh giordano's deep dish
pizza
it's good right now i'm listening yeah
but what if you then asked them when was
the last time they had it they said oh
i've never actually had it oh
would you believe that no i would prefer
not to hang out with that person but
you'd be like how could you say you like
giordano's deep dish pizza if you've
never actually i think i know people
like that we're like yeah like you like
that they're like yeah yeah exactly
exactly so when you say some people like
biden i'm like you're correct but it's
just like that they don't know anything
about them they haven't followed the
news they don't know her care it's just
yeah oh yeah like you know whatever he
is not trump and we just we just pull
out the old post-modern analysis of of
of joe biden and say they're not voting
for biden they're voting for the symbol
of what biden represents they're voting
for the media created image of what
biden would be
if he was actually in charge and running
things we need it we need a comic about
this yeah we're like there's the media's
version of joe biden have you ever seen
uh ben garrison's version of trump yeah
oh my god he's like ripped and he's like
a strong chair
yeah come on please glorious uh and and
and i still voted for the guy but i
recognize that's not that's not trump
trump walks like a duck and he's
overweight right he's been doing better
yeah yeah he's lost
but i would love a comic of like joke
the media's version of joe biden like
the joe biden that exists in the hearts
of minds of hearts and minds of the most
zealot democrats he's like ripped and
chiseled with his aviator sunglasses in
a leather jacket and he's in a
convertible and he's like get in loser
we're saving america and they're like
yay when in reality he's like he can't
speak and he touches kids
yeah well didn't they do a magazine
cover where he was wearing his super
cool aviators and everyone was just like
what is this like we all see this feeble
decrepit old man you guys are trying to
tell us that he's some kind of superhero
but barack obama was right when he said
you should never underestimate joe
biden's um
ability to mess things up i love it i
love i love the people who are like
remember oh obama's only scandal was a
town suit oh my and there are people who
are just like it's like the pizza thing
the people who are just like they'll say
yes i like whatever you say so they all
laugh along and go yeah yeah tan suit
and then i'm just like you remember when
obama killed that kid that american kid
in a civilian restaurant in yemen like
and other civilians yeah you don't want
to talk about scandals operation fast
and furious oh this is a spying scandal
and a safe scandal war on whistleblowers
going after spying on merkel journalists
and whistleblowers more than any other
president before him with this one
particular law i forgot the name of it
the spanish the espionage exactly used
it more than all other presidents
combined exactly yeah so like there's so
many things to talk about the biden
presidency and a lot of people have said
that
a a a a biden presidency is a
continuation of an obama presidency and
there might be some merit to that but
this would be kind of an unmasked obama
uh push that literally is just the
perfect representation of everything
globalists ever wanted it's their
epitome of their wet dream when when it
comes to when when you see what they're
able to achieve a lot of people are
saying oh it was just a mistake oh this
is you know there's just an accident i i
think when you're at that high level of
government i think when you have that
much money that much power i think they
they play things off as as accidents and
mistakes when in reality a lot of this
stuff was deliberate and when you look
at whose interest it serves who it helps
it's usually the people backing these
individuals it's usually the dark money
it's usually a lot of the people that
are behind the scenes that usually are
very influential in governments but
they're the ones that don't get voted on
they don't get elected but they're still
there the bureaucratic state exactly
um
i just i just sent uh
lydia the uh there's a there's a comic
book where they made a comic of hillary
clinton oh my gosh yeah
i forgot about this yeah they did the
superhero we didn't know we needed
yeah okay
and hillary clinton we knew we didn't
want yeah we knew we didn't want her i'm
gonna we don't deserve or need yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 p.m where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you